et alors que l'algérie étant ces
derniers foyers après les incendies
meurtriers de la semaine dernière qui
ont coûté la vie à près de 90 personnes
la police a ouvert une enquête après le
lynchage d'un homme de 38 ans accusé à
tort d'être l'un des pyromanes présumés
les précisions de notre correspondant à
tunis passe m shelly
c'est une affaire qui prend de l'ampleur
en algérie qui fait le tour des réseaux
sociaux des images chocs d'un jeune
homme lynché par la foule aux abords
d'un commissariat de larba nath irathen
près de tizi ouzou en kabylie région du
nord de l'algérie en proie de violents
incendies qui ont coûté la vie à près de
90 personnes pour moi m shakur le
directeur de la police judiciaire
djamel bensmaïl 38 ans s'était rendu à
la police par lui même après avoir
entendu qu'on le soupçonnait d'avoir mis
le feu à une forêt une foule en colère
s'étaient alors amassé aux abords du
commissariat de police bien décidés à en
découdre avec celui qu'on soupçonnait
d'être à tort l'un des pyromanes la
victime a été battue puis brûlé parmi
les 36 suspects interpellés par la
police l'individu qui a poignardé la
victime a été arrêté tandis qu'il
tentait de fuir vers le maroc a déclaré
le directeur de la police judiciaire
lors d'une conférence de presse
soulignant que l' enquête était toujours
en cours un traumatisme selon la ligue
algérienne de défense des droits de
l'homme alors que le père de la victime
a été massivement salués à travers tout
le pays après avoir appelé au calme et à
la fraternité entre algériens alors que
le pays exige que la justice fasse toute
la lumière sur cette affaire qui a
choqué toute une nation ce week-end
encore pompiers militaires et
volontaires ont continué d'éteindre les
derniers feux de forêts qui ravagent la
kabylie depuis lundi dernier